okay welcome to this video rah heisel
rahi zylle wow this is a new opponent
okay but he's got a ton a ton of games
and as I see oh it's funny that you keep
getting new opponents here okay i'm
playing one of my standard openings here
I did experiment some in recent games it
costs me lots of rating points really
liked to have this 2400 you know maybe I
can try to get back to it okay we have a
bogo Catalan hybrid system John with 85
he's taking lots of time early on Bishop
g2 is the normal normal move in the
world okay yeah i'm going nite d7 and e5
wow what is he doing that guy's even
slower than me ah ok and so I think yeah
I should I can and should play or five
directly putting something in the center
may be provoking d5 move like d5 would
be nice to see simply because very often
I have to play it the night out to c6
and then after d if I have to return ok
mmmm interesting ok let's just castle
him and if he cancels i have to take
because Bishop g5 at some point might ok
maybe it was not necessary to do that ok
interesting so what now
just 96 maybe just 96 I guess you will
avoid to play D Phi if this is at least
what I'm expecting I mean you can do
that it's not a bad move but it looks
like more that is trying to keep his
position okay
yeah i can i can just take on d4 but
this looks like a champ I'm not sure
maybe I should do that simple the simple
approach Abbott's okay thinking about it
now maybe I shouldn't have taken on d2n
just taking on deform this looks this
looks a little bit better for whitey
definitely okay that sets a very very
direct play
hmm okay yeah II five year he's really
going all out we five
Jim I can put the night on c5 and maybe
the bishop here Bishop d7 he will play
500 this is so really not very
convenient okay yeah that's not not a
very nice position one idea of this is
to play rook a5 trying to activate the
rook may be there
yeah one problem is that this pressure
on the default makes it very difficult
for me to play the move c6 and without
c6 plate it's a really difficult to to
react to 95 m ok so she can't be six or
something it's not looking nice not at
all oh is this pressure here yeah if I
here maybe you can just play five now
he's got Bishop c6 on the cards
I take here as Bishop c6 on right away
no yeah no I can take first ok I have to
take there anyway huh ok he has to take
with the poem he does not have to take
the pond ok weird
so if i take here Isis doing this whole
invasion thing Bishop's is six
yeah if I ever seen a computer ish play
then it's this time warning what is this
guy is got a ton of games and probably
not a cheater just looks very good very
computer issue okay
I can take c7 now the check on what not
wow that was really really bad now
that's that's not even not even the best
way to play but it's totally enough
hmm okay that's no computer and as I
should have he could have played much
stronger
hmm
well lay is 95 and stuff like that but
I'm still somewhat somewhat alive which
is more than could be expected I can
give this check here and then Bishop g5
that's not really winning yes somehow
I'm still alive
check
I shall see to coming up maybe I was a
child I didn't even see that oh wow okay
the alack resign they played a very bad
technical part of the game from the
position here where I was totally busted
I mean this was really really bad play
but okay I mean this this is this is the
easiest one after which I just resign I
mean this is it is still winning because
it's just so so bad so yeah this is was
probably just bad right especially the
immediate capture was terrible yeah I'm
really not really not getting out of
this really badly thinking about it I
probably should take here this is much
better yeah that's much better play it
like that and then get this Bishop back
to c5 this is a typical way to play it
like 90 NTM that's much much better than
then the game here I just have a
somewhat worse position especially now
the double capture on d4 is really bad
and I mean this is this is better or
it's the problem was that here this this
long diagonal pressure really made me it
says admit it's difficult now for me to
move because II five is such a big
problem is after luke t 1 especially
here i'm just in terrible shape
I still find to see a very computer ish
but but ok movie it's really weird after
that he really played badly yeah
somebody will be at game but of course
it deserved loss after my bed opening
play ok thanks for watching